So you've probably heard
of this cloud thing before.
Network diagrams such as this one
are actually where the term, the cloud,
to mean Internet services, comes from.
The idea is that we don't need to know
what's going on inside this cloud.
It's hidden from us.
All we need to know is what service
we're talking to at the other end and
that the network will get our
message all the way from us to them.
If this is us over here with
a Chrome web browser, and
they're over there with an Apache web
server, we can do an HTTP request and
get a web page back,
even though the network in the middle
doesn't even need to know
that web pages are a thing.
The ping program, on the other hand, is
a little unusual for a network program.
The message that it sends,
called an Echo request,
is received by the destination
system's operating system.
In an application protocol like HTP or
SSH, there's a server program that
composes a response and sends it back.
But with ping, there's no ping server.
The Echo request just goes to the
operating system on the receiving end,
which sends a response back.
Every operating system that supports
Internet access supports ping as well.
So regardless of what
system we're using,
we could ping a system
running any operating system.
Could be Linux, or Windows, or
Mac OS, or BSD, or something else.
There is something to keep in mind is
that although ping is simpler than HTTP,
HTTP is not based on ping.
So let's see what HTTP is built on.